John Stockton ten-time NBA all-star of
course hall-of-famer back in 2009 his
son David playing for the Jazz signed
towards the end of the season John good
to have you on how are you today thank
you thanks dad good morning I'm doing
well how are you when you're watching
the game
how were you last night to be around
pretty calm I mean it's it's a lot
easier watching from your living room
with nobody watching no cameras on you
to see if you're eating pizza or
anything or chatting to friendly I don't
know it's it's pretty calm at the house
what do you look for in a game well I
think I look for look for things like a
coach does I look for habits I look for
momentum I look for what guy's
tendencies are maybe I don't know why
I'm not coaching anything but it's uh
it's kind of what my mo is what is the
position now that's the point guard
position what what is it now as opposed
to what it used to be in your opinion
well it's certainly changed it seems
like the the point guard often is the
focal point where they're they're the
shooter they're the pastor I mean
absolutely everything starts there and
it's a little bit different we had those
certainly when I was playing we had guys
that that were the number one option for
for just about everything but it feels
like there are more two guards playing
one right now then there were my day
how would you be would you be different
if you were playing now with this point
guard position I don't think so I mean I
think that I mean even back in the day
there was like I said there was a lot of
guys there's a lot of different ways to
play that position and I I couldn't have
been better being somebody else's way I
just tried to to play as hard do is what
coach Sloan or coach Lane would ask and
and didn't really put too much thought
into change and I figure it would work I
was wondering who was that first point
guard that was they shoot first past
second you know I always think a Tim
Hardaway was was one of those gun not
not that he wasn't a great passer or
willing passer but it felt like he shot
first and then passed second do you
remember yeah yeah maybe so I mean there
was guys that were on that fringe I had
a chance to play with him a few times
like Kevin Johnson if
times they tended to be a little bit
more shoot-first guys but boy were they
great passers great teammates great
great at just about everything and so
you know that they couldn't be just
characterized well kind of like the guys
today these guys are great pastors as
well but but those are two at least in
the West that really stick out I think
Isaiah Thomas had his moments where
where he was that way as well what when
did you realize that Donovan Mitchell
was going to be the real deal
you know you always doubt that you know
you hear you hear from people that are
rookies it's not all this guy's the real
deal I mean heard a thousand times and
you go yeah ok yeah wait till mid yeah
wait till next time or what whatever but
the kid is really special he's special
in his demeanor he special in his
comments for a guy his age he's special
in his his play and his confidence and
his memory his lack of memory I guess
when things aren't so don't go so great
I just when did I start noticing it
probably about two months after people
started saying it took you that long
yeah I think so did you don't you doubt
it yeah absolutely doubt it like can you
see if you're gonna go most unstoppable
offensive players of all time
now just offense now let's take kareem
out of the the equation here the most
unstoppable offensive players of all
time who would you put on that it would
be in your top five well number one is
and i don't know why you mentioned
kareem already and i'd like a legend you
will take michael out then too okay
right what about Wilt Chamberlain I mean
is there even a second I mean it's they
changed rules for that guy okay how
about since 1980
[Laughter]
a little bit tougher and Michael is
certainly in there yeah I don't think
guys who stopped Karl Malone I don't
think they could stop him today you know
he played within a system but he boy
when it came down I you just couldn't
stop the guy I didn't see Elgin Baylor
or play I know you said since 1980 but
he was special watching these young guys
think guys we're where you're getting at
is just watching a harding it seems like
he might be in that category I'm sure
there's others damn but it's
that's hard for me to cue up but harden
it feels like is unstoppable John it
sure does
let me just didn't watch an Emmy he
doesn't miss shots he doesn't miss
layups he goes to the free-throw line
seemingly a will doesn't miss free
throws I know that's kind of the
impression I get what was your welcome
to the NBA moment you remember well my
very first game Larry Drew picked me
right midcourt i dribbled up the court
and we're in Kansas City and he just
took it from me and it wasn't very
crowded some guy in the stands yelled C
ba ba and I went wow welcome to the big
time did anybody ever talk trash to you
I was told they did I didn't notice it I
mean I've been told that I've been I was
fairly focused and I'm sure people guys
did and and I was also remember a guy
yelling I mean one game because I didn't
respond to his trash talking and he just
kept yelling talk to me all of a sudden
occurred to me that he had been talking
to me so uh anyway I think I missed out
on a lot was that Jordan who was saying
talk to me no no no actually he didn't
talk much we had a we had one exchange
in our entire careers and our careers
matched out we came in the same years
etc but we only had really one exchange
a fairly heated one but it was it was a
really trash talking that I recall what
was that about and he did exchange oh it
was a foul going on I mean there was I
think Randy Brown was in the game at the
time and and Michael took offense to
something that went in there and he
checked himself in and then we had the
very next play and and he got a foul and
he said something I was he's locking
welcome back to the bench and I said
something back again yet you're kind of
things fade over time so I've forgotten
the actual details but that was it yeah
cuz Jordan I think is saying you play
dirty too you know I I felt more respect
for Michael than that frankly I mean he
he played as hard as anybody and as
physically as anybody and you know I
never sensed those types of comments
from him ever
never said anything well he did but not
to me I remember as a rookie he came in
he walked by our bench at the Salt
Palace and said I feel like 43 and he
came out he scored 43 in the third
quarter and checked checked himself out
of a 20-point victory and was fairly
impressed with that one so he just picks
a random number I feel like 43 and he
says it to you to the bench did you ever
feel like you can have one of those
nights where you could get 50 not the
NBS that's some really good felt
accurate spoke yeah but no no it was you
know back to the past first thing it
wasn't the way I was wired I seldom do
you get those many shot opportunities
when you're when you're I guess looking
for passes an opportunity to get other
guys involved but no never never even
considered it he's a John Stockton the
Hall of Famer ten time NBA all-star did
you ever play a pickup game and not tell
anybody who you were
oh well I never told anybody
no I didn't I played in races if you
pick up games after I was in with the
Jazz that I didn't initiate the you know
it was my key to the gym or whatever but
no it's not something I would tell
people anyway Do You Know Who I am
well no like did you ever show up in a
playground like drive by and you just
show up and then like you never did that
I'm trying to think about it you know I
guess I could see myself doing that with
a couple little kids maybe out in the
playground I wouldn't do it in the real
game I think that is recipe for disaster
but maybe a couple little kids somewhere
online I might have done that when you I
try to tell kids or parents of kids
little things you know we had Ray Allen
on the other day and and Ray brought up
what he used to do and you see this with
Steph Curry he practices shots
off-balance shots shots he's gonna take
in the game instead of everybody just
stands there and shoots jumpers and
going man I got a great shot when you're
in the moment that's when we want to
find out what you can do
what is your advice on playing the point
guard position or you know passing or
whatever in general that you can pass on
to kids or their parents well first of
all passing is probably the hardest
thing to practice on your own he really
sort of throw it to the wall yeah we do
some of that you know you run down that
run down the length of a wall and you
throw behind the back passes to yourself
as you're running I mean I think anytime
you're handling the ball you're
improving those things but you can't
necessarily improve the vision and the
anticipation and some of the nuances
that come with it but you know shooting
for sure I remember even coach view with
the with Gonzaga here he'd watch me do
my shooting over the course of the
summer so why are you practicing those
things you know things in the paint off
balance off one leg underhanded spin
ease you know things like that I say
because they come into play not all the
time but it may be a big time and when
you need it and you know something I
pretty much live by it it's you have to
practice odd things could you have been
a quarterback in football if not knowing
how tough that is and I did play
quarterback growing up and I loved it I
was so tiny
that I couldn't see over the line very
well and the hits hurt but I think I got
a little bit bigger older and and I I do
think I could have played that position
I think I like how things move out there
and you kind of read those types
activities and it would have been fun to
try if nobody hit yeah but that's what I
was wondering though do you see the
field the way I like Tom Brady does do
you see the floor the way he sees the
field do you have to see it less people
but is there any similarity with that I
sure think so you know people turning
their heads
the direction of their bodies as they're
running you know you throw people open
your throat where they aren't so to
speak you know you got your guy can get
to a spot the defense can't yeah that's
where you throw it so yeah I think there
has to be some similarities has to be
what was it like when magic was bringing
the ball up the floor when somebody's
six nine and he's playing the same
position as you well first I had a
chance to watch him you know as a young
kid high school whatever and everybody
idolized him and we we were all copying
his moves in the driveway and things
like that and then I had a chance to
play against him and
for me he was one of the most difficult
guys just for me to guard he was so big
and six nine is probably an
understatement by the way but he just
kind of turned his body and kept you on
his hip and oversaw everything and yet
he had he had moves and and could get
get corners on he could get by you and
once he got by you it was over and then
obviously his vision and passing ii and
a really special guy special player who
was the toughest guy in the garden well
Ricky's were tough to guard as a general
rule but guys out west guys that we
played every day I mentioned Kevin
Johnson Tim Harvey Larry out later on
Gary Payton out back east Isiah Thomas
Mark Price they're just they're just a
lot of great players and great
challenges but Magic Johnson again
because the size we usually guard it in
with Bobby Hansen our to guard and and
ID guard someone else whoever was
smaller at the time Byron Scott usually
but but you were talking about it's
tough to guard rookies because you don't
have a book on them there's no scouting
report yeah they've seen you a lot
typically a lot of those kids guys
coming out usually have seen all the NBA
guys a lot so they kind of know you
they're there frost out there ready to
go and kind of have a little chip on
their shoulder have something to prove
and and they're pretty good you know so
it's it was always a challenge when you
saw the new guys coming around I thought
would the Utah Jazz have been a better
team with today's rules with spreading
the floor instead of you know feels like
it was a two-man game inside outside and
you know having big men you know you had
guys who could shoot but would you be
better equipped for today's game or were
you better suited for you know back when
you played both ways I think our stuff
would work now I mean I think it's not
in vogue certainly but to have to guard
a team over picks to have to guard them
for the full clock to to then have to
deal with a guy like Karl Malone at the
end of it I think people would have
trouble playing against a team like us
now I think they have lots of troubles
with it you know I've had people ask me
a lot they said you put your man you
couldn't even play in today's game and
because people can't you know you
touch people you can do this I said well
no but they can't touch us either and so
you know yeah I confidently I'm an old
guy now I can't I mean I couldn't guard
anybody now so it feels helped helpless
but you know I think there's a place for
guys that figure it out in their era to
play in almost any era and that goes
back to the you know Bill Russell kuzhi
kuzhi days I think those guys you put
them in our game and and even though the
film's wouldn't indicate it
I think they'd figure it out just like
we did but so you have people who don't
think you could play in today's game
right yeah you're still fighting John
you know they still you're a Hall of
Famer and you still have to prove that
you can you can play I feel bad for you
thank God I don't have to prove it
anymore it's just it is what it is did
you keep the short shorts do you do you
have that's one thing to keep a uniform
but did you keep your short shorts yeah
every once in a while I had one my son
played ball my son Michael played ball
over in Europe with Kobe Karl George
cause somehow he got ahold of some old
shorts of mine and Kobe returned them
after what 25 years and so we've got a
pair floating around the house right now
I think they should have Stockton short
night's shorts night with the Jazz maybe
next season well I'll get you in touch
with the PR department and maybe you can
have some pool with them but I think the
short shorts are coming back any way
they're comfortable you know I couldn't
I could never stand the long shorts and
and I think guys are coming out once
what's it becomes uncool again they'll
notice they're comfortable and start
wearing them all right so you're in
though John if I can get John's time in
short night's shorts night I got to get
it figured out here John but you're in
and you'll wear your you'll wear your
shorts well that might be pushing come
on I don't look quite as good in them as
I used to maybe I don't know
hey have fun during the postseason here
and hopefully David's doing well thanks
for joining us John
I appreciate you asking thanks dad
that's it John Stockton ten time NBA
all-star Hall of Famer four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]